on a le jury de miss france 100% féminin
dévoilé alors ça y est qu'est ce que
vous pensez du jury 100% féminin déjà à
malika de l'idée c'est une opération de
communication ça fait parler ça marche
puisque on apparaît c'est vrai mais bon
c'est sympa et de toute façon le
l'influencent du jury est ce que c'est
important quand on est miss de le jury
on s'en fout totalement non tu t'en fous
parce qu'en fait c'est ce que tu vois en
premier quand tu es défilent cesser
leurs regards que tu caps et ceux du
jury après bon après il y avait avant il
y avait alain delon savait qu'on allait
avoir de voir ce sont d'alain delon et
que des mof chimiste est contenté dire
la talassia loti première saison mais ça
va peut-être les détendre un peu de pas
avoir des hommes et après non mais c'est
vrai parce que moi je vois tous les mecs
qui ont été choisis à chaque fois c'est
ils sont comme des oufs sur les miss
quoi voilà jean pierre foucault il est
toujours c'est un hamac là sinon je
pense c'est la classe oui on l'embrassé
doit nourrir des toits delphine c'est
important pour toi le jury ou pas oui
effectivement en fait quand tu vas au
bout du procès niyum tu les vois donc
c'est à eux que tu fais un petit clin
d'oeil en espérant que en chopant leur
regard ils vont voter pour toi ou
effectivement vachement une influence à
les limiter parce que de toute façon
c'est son public bien je suis douze
présélectionnés avant alors on sait
qu'ils vont être les quatre femmes
lesquelles il fallait quatre autres
femmes à s'asseoir aux côtés de jennifer
et laury thilleman puisque le jennifer a
fait une petite gaffe chez laurent
ruquier
voilà sur sa présence dans le jury miss
france mais c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
qu'il faut si dany faire et il s'agit
donc de la joueuse de tennis caroline
garcia
c'est la française année dans le dock
dans le top 10 1 l'humoriste claudia
tagbo la comédienne mode becker et et la
danseuse étoile
alice run avons voilà donc ce seront les
six représentantes du jury je pense que
gilles verdez de se retourner les mains
si elles sont toujours à l'île maurice
actuellement et on vient également
d'apprendre
[Musique]
on vient d'apprendre
assurances pro x alors et les miss se
sont toujours à l'île maurice on vient
également d'apprendre tous les cadeaux
qu'elle allait recevoir de la part du
comité miss france
à chaque fois il ya plein de cadeaux il
ya des voitures vous avez une voiture
vous ouais je les invendus depuis away
c'est quoi c'était quoi ces think you
mais c'était toujours une peugeot on
embrasse renault également il y en aura
bien sûr la dame skoda ce que vous avez
eu une boîte moi si j'ai une peugeot une
207 cc que j'ai gardé parce que je suis
très émotif c'était ma première voiture
ça devient fota aurait en plus avec la
bride au lit oui cabriolet modèle roland
garros elle est trop chouette et si les
gars madjid et chez toi il ya delphine
wespiser elle vient de chercher un coupé
cabriolet et a en même temps le moment'
à beinheim qui passe en calèche
[Applaudissements]
dans une période où la place des femmes
dans la société est au coeur des débats
le comité miss france a décidé de
marquer l'occasion en sélectionnant pour
la première fois de son existence un
jury entièrement composé de femmes
une petite révolution annoncée par la
présidente du comité sylvie tellier il
ya quelques jours
et si on savait que la présidente du
jury cette année la comédienne line
renaud les noms des autres membres ont
été dévoilées la chanteuse jenifer
l'humoriste claudia tagbo la comédienne
de demain nous appartient mode baker la
danseuse étoile
alice renavand la tennis woman carole
garcia et laury thilleman miss france
2011 feront partie de ce nouveau cru un
jury qui aura la difficile mission
d'aider les téléspectateurs à choisir
parmi les 30 candidates laquelle mérite
le 15 décembre prochain d'être couronnée
miss france 2010 9
j'étais pas pour le 100% femmes parce
que je trouvais voilà que ça faisait
trop opération de com mais j'aime bien
quand même caroline garcia je suis fan
absolu
claudia tagbo je kiffe laury thilleman
sympathie eu pas mal non dit est ce que
bon jury au mauvais jury oui madame moi
je les aime bien tout séparément et bien
sûr je continue à trouver à ne pas
comprendre de tout l'intérêt et la
nécessité de faire un jury semble des
personnes intéressées se trouve que
c'est l'opportunisme de l'air du temps
je suis très content si ça avait été sur
m6 ou une vision très très con bien sûr
non mais moi je voulais pas mais eux non
les hypothèses non moi je trouve ça
moche que séquelles des fortes
personnalités et moi j'ai pour habitude
de peut juger un truc que je connais pas
donc je veux je vais regarder maladie ça
un coup de com et c'est que des grosses
personnalités moi j'aime l'art c'est des
boyer hier madame conduite va passer on
s'en fou comme il a dit à leurs deux
hommes il va mieux elle va faire un
suçon parfois c'est vrai c'est maladroit
ile de france 10 h sympa tous déçus ce
bel adam castaldi dans son pull
magnifique a beau début et vous allez
toucher ça ou pas non mais j'en ai rien
à [ __ ]
pas de mixité c'est important c'est
l'élection de miss france pourquoi
pourquoi que les filles franchement ça
n'a pas de sens ça n'a pas de sens c'est
à nouveau opposé les hommes aux femmes
alors comme ça voudrait dire en
sous-texte que les hommes sont pas aptes
à juger des femmes parce que ce serait
balances ton port est carrément des
obsédés alors que padilla là où pour
l'instant le public à 70% dit mauvais
jury 1 oui monsieur est déjà moins jury
jamais il y avait déjà de la moitié
jugent que je ne connais pas grand monde
et évidemment mais imaginez ma mère ça
se règle sur le mister france et que les
sommes qu'ils jugent possible que nous
trouvions pas ça complètement débile qui
est pas de femmes qui juge la bouche et
des dégâts seraient mais je serai monter
au créneau et moi ou c'est pareil oui
voilà
ben moi je sûr selon quels critères
elles choisissent en fait là surtout
parce que ce serait pas mal de le faire
dans le noir c est moi c'est l'amour est
aveugle reste émission oui madame
moi je trouve que sylvie tellier elle
innove ça c'est bien en revanche en
revanche j'aurais préféré si elle veut
donner la place aux femmes qu'elles
suppriment les preuves en maillot de
bain comme l'a fait aux états unis miss
america ml chacun son avis mais je veux
valoriser l'intellect des femmes c'est
un peu faire des réponses en doudoune
états unis mais didier rappeur ils font
différemment c'est pas des zombies je me
suis intéressé nouveaux articles achetés
des miss france c'est un concours on
juge la plus belle fille au global
intérieur extérieur donc c'est important
le discours c'est important le test de
culture générale et c'est important de
les voir en maillot de bain bien des
c'est aussi un oeil masculin et la
beauté d'une femme via le très bien si
c'est une bonne idée de comme tu l'as
dit ma lecture je pense que ça va être
qu'une simple série pas dire si
j'emmerde tout le monde me breton
[Applaudissements]